so the Russia story is just huge some
believable there's nothing more
important they hacked our democracy
Putin's in charge every American cares
we know that well I don't know how we
know it because the new USA Today poll
shows that literally less than 1% of
voters say that so-called Russian
meddling is their top election issue for
2018 CNN hasn't seen the poll obviously
they don't care because tonight they're
running something called Trump and
Russia a CNN investigation which
describes your programming everyday
hilarious we've been hearing about
Russian non-stop literally non-stop for
more than a year almost no information
has come out to justify the obsession
none has come out to justify the claim
that there was collusion and most
Americans are no longer interested if
they ever were so what's going on here
Robin burrow is a former Regional
Director for Barack Obama's presidential
campaign and he joins us tonight
thanks for coming on so this is
confusing to me because normally you'd
say look maybe the Democratic Party and
their propaganda arm in the media just
didn't explain this well enough that's
not true that it actually really worked
hard to make this palatable to explain
it to unpack it as we say in the media
they've been relentless in their
presentation of this and people still
don't care so why is that do you think
why do Americans not care it's not the
question yeah why don't Americans know
because we've been hearing about this
for over a year this is an ongoing
investigation as you know very little
trickles out from an ongoing FBI
investigation because Muller is building
a case so he's given us you know we've
got little tidbits of what who has
testified to the house Intel committee
but that's about it so after hearing
about this for a year without much
information coming out as it should not
because they're still building a case
you know there's just not a lot to go on
Americans are more concerned about
what's happening at home with their
pocketbooks what's happening with their
taxes what's going on when they're gonna
get their tax refunds there's a lot of
other things I think that Americans are
concerned about right well I think
you're absolutely right there I mean I
agree with you completely so but that's
it's just sort of interesting so you're
saying that we don't really know
anything so why would they care and yet
the news coverage is literally
wall-to-wall I'm not over staying
I've got a Bank of TVs in my office I
keep the stand off because you know just
masochistic to turn it up but I see the
screen all day long and it's all Russia
all day long for more than a year so if
we don't know anything what are they
talking about yeah you know I watched
about ten minutes of Rachel Maddow and
that it was like an obsession so I
understand that the media you know on
other networks do they are obsessed with
this but the public does seem to have
lost interest in this and I totally
understand why because we just don't
have enough information right now maybe
if more information came out now when we
got the the noonas memo that good that
was a big story we got that the
Democratic memo didn't seem to Jenn ups
as much interest but right now the
Russian meddling story just it's just
not really resonating with everyday
Americans being now fair let me just say
I was unfair to end this all in the
media I mean really the core concern
comes from their paymasters in the
Democratic Party whose interest they
serve and so it's really Democrats
who've been driving this and we've had a
bunch of them on this show nice people
yes but if they don't know anything why
are they so obsessed and why aren't they
talking about things that Americans
actually care about I wish I knew I take
a lot of issue with my own party job but
we have there's a lot that we can
improve on we need a coherent message to
deliver to Americans other than just
resist we need to be giving them ideas
where we can maybe improve their lives
other than just giving them you know
promises of resistance of illegal aliens
here and giving them citizenship and
voting rights I thought that they
chucked on the government over that
remember that that was the top priority
the democratic party do you think that's
a win around 2018
no it wouldn't have been a winner for
either party I think I think you know
honestly if we were to take apart that
issue it wouldn't have helped either
party to have mass deportations of young
people who are in college maybe serving
in our military I'm a veteran I served
with some of these guys in the military
so you know I don't think that would
have played favor with any either party
so I understand the concern there but
you know I just need that much
parties in the middle of my party gosh I
don't have the number right in front I
do actually
why did I send up two for gang activity
than served in the US military just to
kind of put it in perspective yeah no I
get what you're saying I understand it's
a legitimate concern you know I'm a
pretty conservative Democrat I'm more of
a blue dog democrat so we probably agree
on some of the some of these issues your
party the Russia's stuff I mean look if
we find out that Trump trying and
plotting you know would takeover of the
West from you know they're a hot tub or
whatever then that's a real story but
geez now I would always I would always
say that you know the protection of our
way democracy is very important so I
agree with that we're trying you know I
just want let's just let this thing run
out and after if Trump gets exonerated
he should be a happy man there you go
thanks Robin good to see you